get the latest analysis of the situation
on the ground in Ukraine joining me
again in the studio is the defense and
security analyst Professor Michael
clarkello again Michael looking at this
map here talk us through the second
phase what are we hearing from the
Russian military what is their intent
well the Russian military are pushing
they're pushing from east to west and
they've acknowledged the ukrainians have
acknowledged that the about 40 odd
villagers uh East in the Donetsk region
have fallen but those are only Villages
the Russians are concentrating on
chromatosk and they really want
crematores because part of this line
they want to draw from north to south
but this whole adventure of theirs which
they're now saying is for the East and
the whole of the south of the country
its distance that's the issue is 300
miles north to south and then another
300 miles from the donbass right through
to Moldova which they're now talking
about the transnation district to model
it so these are Big distances the
ukrainians are holding them at the
moment but these are very early days
what ukrainians now need is the heavy
metal they need the tanks the armored
fighting Vehicles the artillery Joe
Biden announced yesterday another 800
million in military aid which included
72 of the very good 155 millimeter
howitzers that's great but what the
ukrainians need is not 72 of them they
need 200 or 300 of them to make a to
make a game-changing difference so it's
a sort of logistics race that's going on
at the moment now the world's eyes have
been focused not just on Ukraine but in
particular uh this place here Mario Pole
now the last stand there seems to be
taking place at a steel Works what is
the latest situation yes uh it looks
like about a thousand troops underneath
the as of style steel Works maybe a
thousand civilians maybe 500 wounded
civilians and Military
um the Russians have said that they
won't go in after them that they'll just
screen them and move on and that's a
sensible thing uh President Putin
announced it with great Fanfare
yesterday talking to his defense
minister because he said fact that he
didn't even want to fly to be able to
escape from exactly well you know his
commander on the ground dwornikov could
have worked that out for himself I mean
no sensible Commander sends people into
fight in the tunnels against a desperate
enemy who've got nothing to lose
um Russian media in recently have
started to report that the Russians are
prepared to allow safe passage for
everybody out of the avastar steel works
that may be true a question will be will
the will the ukrainians believe them
because they may it makes perfect public
relations sense for the Russians to say
that and it will get the steelworks off
the map take it away as a problem but
what will they do with the Ukrainian
soldiers were they send them to a prison
war camp where they take them around the
back somewhere and shoot them or would
they just send them home they don't
trust them that's the point the the
ukrainians I suspect will not take
advantage of that maybe except for the
civilians and then there's the images
that have appeared overnight from maxar
the satellite company and this is an
image from a place called manhole which
is uh sorry um
yeah manhole which is a a village about
20 kilometers outside uh Maria pole it
is a cemetery Municipal cemetery and
this image was taken on the 19th of
March on the 3rd of April another image
shows a lot of area of new Graves about
200 new Graves that have been created we
don't know who's in those Graves the
Russian military May well say well those
are Ukrainian soldiers that we buried
with full respect ukrainians may say no
they're civilians who've been illegally
killed chances are we won't know for
quite some time which of those is likely
to be nearer to the truth well quite
horrifying images either way aren't they
okay yeah Michael thank you very much